what is up guys my name is a chino or
yan
you know because the journey is not
really on my birth certificate but
whatever you can call me on if you want
and welcome to something completely
different welcome to the first video of
a series of videos in which i am going
to attempt or we are going to attempt to
create a 3d game in java from scratch
using no game engines using no OpenGL
interfaces like LW j GL lightweight java
game library nothing except the inbuilt
libraries in the java 1.6 okay so from
scratch from zero from this from not
even a project and yeah so at this rate
probably like a first-person shooter or
something like that you know we'll see
mostly how this goes
now I assume that you guys have a bit of
knowledge have it you know a bit of
knowledge of Java you know you've done a
bit of Java maybe I don't expect you
guys to be able to write your own
programs but I just want you guys to
understand the syntax if you don't or if
you've done no Java but you really want
to or whatever there'll be a link in the
description of this video that will link
you to the new Boston's Java tutorials
because they are really good they're the
best soils on YouTube in my opinion on
on Java and that's not how I learnt
unfortunately but I do i do tell
everyone tech to go look at them they're
interested in learning so yeah ok let's
start this is eclipsed by the way
eclipse is in my opinion the best IDE
for Java when IDE is sort of like a
program which reels like helps you helps
you write code because it it it compiles
it for you you know lets you debug the
code it shows you all the errors in your
code there's a nice little outline over
here you know and it it's basically it's
you need to have one of these I've used
other ones like Java beans and IntelliJ
IDEA I actually used the latter for a
while but eclipse is in my opinion the
best and also you know not uses it it's
going to be a major selling point
minecraft was made on it so there we go
it's good yeah so
first thing we're gonna do is create a
new project so oh by the way if you want
to download eclipse there'll be a um
there'll be a link in the description of
this video where you can download it for
Windows for Mac for Linux anything you
want Java works everywhere unlike you
know C++ so yeah I'm gonna create a new
Java project file new Java project we'll
be using one point seven I think that's
still in beta I'm not sure but um anyway
we're gonna be using one point six so
make sure to some one point six I'm
gonna call this project mine front
because mine front is actually a game
that I'm working on and I can't think of
any other name at the moment so my in
front of this um and yeah you start to
have a project name you can type
whatever you want and hit finish it's
gonna create a new project over here is
you can say yeah so the first thing we
need to do is create a new class now a
class is basically like a group of code
it's because what what what we need in
the beginning is like a class to
basically tell the program okay what we
want to do is create a new window we
want to put you know our content in the
window you know they're all of that
stuff we need it when it in we need a
group of code which tells us to sort of
initialize the program and later on
initialize the main game loop which will
update you know however many times per
second frames per second all that stuff
well we'll get to that soon I'm just
gonna call this display because this
code will sort of be all of our display
stuff in writing here and we want to put
it into a package now it's the I've so
I've thought about how to describe this
and in my opinion I think the best way
to describe this is probably to to say
that you don't want to leave your source
code out in the front garden you sort of
want to put it into the house and into
the kitchen or the bedroom you know it's
not necessarily a woman so yeah you
could put it into the bedroom sit at the
kitchen but yeah and the way that we do
this is we sort of dots are like back
slashes or false lashes or whatever but
in Java they're dolls they indicate
folder
so inside calm they'll be a folder
called mime and then they'll be folded
back hold mine front so I'm just putting
it into a series of folders this is just
good practice in Java what everyone does
I would create this but I'm gonna type
it by hand I'm gonna type it you know
just in front of you guys so that you
can see exactly what I'm doing yeah so
once you've filled out a package and
once you've filled out a name for the
class hit finish and first thing I wish
bugs me is that we don't have line
numbers so I'm just gonna go ahead and
look editors text that is sure line
numbers okay so in general editors and
then text editors sure line numbers and
now I got you know how many lines of
code we've typed or how many exists
anyway so yeah that's the first useful
thing okay so basically what I want to
do today is I want to just create a
window that's that's how that's our goal
for this video basically cuz I really
want to explain this in as much detail
as possible which is gonna be hard if I
type a lot of code and I've thought
about this a lot and it's actually my
first time trying to record this because
it ends up being like half an hour long
I'm not even joking
so all we want to do here is create a
window so the way we do this is we want
to create two integers in stands for
integer it's a keyword in Java we need
to give that a name so we'll call it
width and then we want to set it equal
to an integer so to a number with our
decimal points 800 okay that's how wide
we want to have it for now we can change
that later we'll also need to create an
integer for the height oh and by the way
I'm doing this like I'm doing this
completely off the top of my head like
all this game programming stuff this
will pretty much be you know life I
guess on the fly so I don't know what
I'm creating yet well we'll work we'll
work on it together so yeah so I'll
probably go back and fix some things and
explain why I'm doing that and so on and
so forth the other thing we want to do
is we want to create a main method so
public static void main cretinous array
of strings
okay and basically what this this is
like this method is like a group of code
inside the group of code and the reason
we have to create this one is when our
program starts it looks for the main
method and the thing is that it'll it'll
do it'll execute whatever code is inside
here like it'll obviously execute
everything but it will it will sort of
start over here and this basically I
guess really hard to explain basically
you need this to run a program you need
this method if you don't know what a
method is again link in the description
to the new boston's tutorials they're
excellent view them they're really good
and they'll really help you follow along
with this okay so the first thing we
need to do is we need to create an
object of this display actually first of
all let's just extend canvas canvas is a
number it's an inbuilt thing into Java
of Java or AWT and this will help us
this will this is pretty much required
in order to UM create a window display
game equals new display okay so what I'm
doing here is I'm creating an object
Java is an object-oriented programming
language the first thing we need to do
is we need to create an object of this
class called display we've named the
object game so as yeah so basically
we've got now we can work with something
and we and whenever we want to sort of
call this display we use the keyword
game because that's what we've throat
you could call this the churner you
could call this you could call this
whatever you want okay it doesn't matter
we're gonna it was gonna call it game
just so that it's easy for us to know
next thing we want to do is we want to
create a jframe now a jframe is it's
like a frame it's like a window but in
Java it's called the J for him and we
need to import it as well it did it
automatically I don't know I don't even
know how that works sometimes I didn't
poor stuff automatically sometimes it
doesn't
whatever okay so now we're gonna frame
first thing we need to do in order to
create the frame is just go frame dot
it's actually in our frame don't add
again so we're adding this into our game
this isn't actually a different
but we'll work on that later frame darts
set resizable to false we don't want to
be able to resize it notice I'm using
the word frame that's because we we've
set frame over here if I again call this
the churner then I'd have to you know
change all this into the chanter and
that would still work of course but I'm
just gonna leave it as frame frame darts
what else we want setvisible we want it
to be visible sure we want to set a size
to it that's for sure and the size will
be width height okay what are you
hearing me oh yeah public static final
and public is like the the view thing so
it's sort of it's specifying who's going
to be able to view that number view that
integer the static means it's a constant
yes I'm not it's not gonna change final
means that have come be changed either
because we don't want our size to change
at any point at least for now and yeah
that that should be let's just hit OK
you want to hit this debug button at the
top and that will debug your code that
will show you code okay awesome
wonderful we've got a frame at only 10
minutes while I'm running over time it
doesn't matter we'll keep going so we've
got a nice frame here yeah okay we need
to add some code right now called framed
up set default close operation to Geoff
Ram dot X it on close this is really
this is really important because
basically what's going to happen is I'll
show you guys if we try and change the
width and height by the way it's just
going on okay and it's not gonna do in
this case but um it's not going to just
debug this it's still running as you can
see it's hasn't been terminated yet so
you need to manually terminate it in
that case um which is not good because
basically what we want to do is every
time we hit that close button
we wanted to terminate itself and the
best way to check this is if we just
simply print system dot print line
system dot out dot print line what are
you doing
print line and we can print you're
running then if we hit debug then you'll
see that it says running and when we
close this it's stuck it's not gonna be
terminated we'll have to manually
terminate it but if we add this code in
that's a comment by the way double full
slash if you guys don't get anything
just really don't hesitate to leave a
comment or ask me what's up
but seriously look look at that look at
the new boston's tutorials if you don't
understand this it's they're very good
yeah so we'll yeah and now you'll see
that if we hit the exit button it's
gonna terminate for us which is
wonderful other thing that bugs me at
the moment is the location relative to
null that'll actually make it in the
center of our screen okay sometimes you
got to put the Oh one more thing we have
to do is pack the frame okay don't worry
about this it's supposed to be in the
middle sometimes you gotta put it onto
something I don't know it's dodgy there
we go
one more thing we'll do before we finish
this video is we'll create a title and
we'll also create a default serial
version ID don't worry about that that's
the Java thing so let's go public static
final string this time so string is a
bunch of characters it's like a sentence
or a word whatever and we'll call this
title we're called will hold a string
title and we'll call it I don't know
mine front
pre pre-alpha 0.01 whatever just make it
sound cool and of course we need to go
framed set title and title and there we
go if we hit debug you'll see that we
have mine from pre alpha 0.01 on the
screen
okay and
yeah that's pretty much it yeah so
that's been the first tutorial if you
guys don't understand anything let me
know in comments and if you if you want
more like the video add it to your
favorites do whatever do whatever you
want um and yeah so next time we're
gonna gonna look at the at the main game
loop and basically we're gonna just move
on and continue making this game from
scratch so I'll see you guys later bye
[Music]